in the past week there has been a
disaster in Hungary a very sad one in
which the so-called red sludge from
processing of aluminium has escaped from
the pond where it was being held and
chemically this has had quite serious
consequences
so Hungary is a landlocked country right
in the middle of the Europe its rivers
flow into the Danube which goes right
across Europe and into the Black Sea
Hungary is also country where there
quite a few minerals and in this case
they were processing aluminium aluminium
is a very common mineral or element it's
found all over the world in clays and so
on but there is a particular mineral
called bulk site which is hydroxide of
aluminium which is usually found mixed
with iron oxide rust to you and me and
titanium dioxide which is what you get
in white paint and the processing is
chemically pretty trivial everything is
dissolved up in caustic soda sodium
hydroxide and then out of this you get
alumina pure aluminum oxide which is
what process to make aluminum but this
process generates a lot of waste and the
waste is red because it contains rust
so-called red sludge and this is done in
many places in the world in Australia
for example and you get huge ponds of
this large but Australia by comparison
with Hungary is a very sparsely
populated country so the danger from
these lakes is much less and what
happened in this tragic occasion is that
the wall which I think was made of mud
which retained this Lodge gave way at
least in part and the sludge came out
and seven people were killed and I think
probably though I don't know the details
they're more likely to be killed because
they were engulfed in mud and then
because of any of the chemistry but the
sodium hydroxide makes the sludge
alkaline alkaline is the opposite of
acid and because of the way
there is a danger that the sludge can
then get into the rivers and go all the
way down to the Black Sea
fortunately sodium hydroxide is not a
terribly dangerous chemical it makes the
water alkaline and in principle you can
neutralize it by putting in some acid
but you've got to make the acid just the
right amount or you make the river too
acid which is just as bad and when you
mix it in it's not like mixing acid in a
beaker you've got a huge river so how
you add it is quite difficult about 10
or 15 years ago there was a similar
tragedy in Hungary where cyanide came
out from a gold mine and cyanide can't
be neutralized and he's far far more
poisonous and he went all the way down
the Danube to the sea killing fish
thousands of miles away from where it
originated
so the problem in this case is that the
volume of the red sludge is very large
in fact it's possible that some more may
come out after the first release and so
it is difficult to know what is the best
way to treat it but I think the
take-home message is that whenever
people are processing chemicals or
minerals on the large scale you have to
think beforehand what will happen if
something gets out not wait for the
disaster to take place and then start
deciding what to do as far as I'm aware
by and large the red sludge is just left
and nobody is quite sure what to do with
it eventually I think the red sludge
could be treated with acid to make it
neutral but by and large there isn't
very much that can be done with it and
it is the price that we pay for using
aluminium in our takeaway microwave food
in our wrappers of sweets and so on one
cannot
obtain these riches from the earth
without generating some waste what we
have to do is to try and minimize the
amount of that waste and look after it
carefully